the existence of enormous sea serpents
or dragons has been mentioned in
numerous mythologies and religions
greek
norse mesopotamian
judaism
and christianity are just a few
the creature known as leviathan appears
in many different stories and its
origins are rooted in far more than just
one culture
so let's take a look at some of these
origins
before we go any further today's video
has been sponsored by private internet
access the world's most transparent vpn
that will never store or log your data a
vpn or virtual private network allows
you to connect to the web using a remote
server this means your data is encrypted
and your ip address is hidden keeping
your browsing history and personal
details safe from your isp the
government and any other prying eyes
this also means you can change your ip
and location for me this is the feature
i use most if you enjoy streaming tv
shows and movies you may have come
across content not available in your
country simply change your location
using private internet access and that
content is no longer restricted you can
use private internet access to protect
up to 10 devices it's available on all
platforms and they have a wide range of
payment options to try it yourself and
save up to 83 percent of a three-year
subscription and get two months free for
as little as two dollars and eight cents
a month use the link private internet
access dot com slash mythology fiction
explained or click on the link in the
description to take advantage of this
great offer
when we covered peter binsfeld's
classification of demons leviathan
appeared as one of the seven princes of
hell the prince of envy
scholars such as thomas aquinas
described it as a demon responsible for
punishing those guilty of envy by
swallowing them whole
this led to the idea that leviathan may
mean more than just an enormous sea
creature it was a place where the damned
would be sent
its gaping moor was thought to represent
the gates of hell
if we go by the greek old testament and
the book of revelation leviathan is a
term when translated that means dragon
dragons and serpents were not terms that
were as defined as they are today they
normally refer to very similar creatures
in ancient texts
the old testament doesn't directly
associate leviathan with the devil but
the book of revelation speaks of a
mighty battle between god and a
seven-headed dragon which is symbolic of
evil and the devil
during this conflict there were two
monsters summoned that sided with the
dragon the first beast came from the
abyss and the second the earth chapter
13 of the book of revelation describes
the first beast as rising from the sea
hence the association with the leviathan
in the story where jonah is swallowed by
a whale there are some biblical scholars
who instead believe this could have been
the leviathan
it's not until the book of job that we
see the name leviathan a monster of the
sea that mankind is helpless to overcome
sharp teeth and scaled is a fairly
ambiguous description which is why the
debate as to what creature may have
inspired the leviathan is still ongoing
i've seen suggestions ranging from an
enormous crocodile a giant whale
a multi-headed sea serpent or perhaps
just one of the many extinct species
that used to inhabit our ocean
it's common in judaism to see leviathan
paired with the behemoth similar to the
beasts we discussed earlier leviathan a
monster that inhabits the ocean and
behemoth a monster found on land the
book of enoch isn't biblical canon but
it does describe leviathan as a female
monster that dwells in the depths of the
ocean and the behemoth as its male
counterpart found in the desert
these two monsters were separated by god
and when the end comes they shall be
slain and served as food to all those
deemed as righteous
this essentially means when the time
comes god will slay these monsters to
save his creations but only his
followers will be allowed to feast
in this account leviathan is described
as a great fish the talmud echoes this
idea however it goes a tad further its
skin will be flayed and cover the tent
where the feast takes place
if one does not consume its flesh they
will be given clothing made from its
skin
the remaining skin will be spread across
the walls of jerusalem where its
brightness is said to illuminate the
world
now you would assume in order to cover
an entire city this would have to be one
really big fish
one description in the town would states
it was a creature with horns on its head
a gaping jaw and a body that is 300
miles long
numerous stories in the midrash describe
encounters and they often involve
someone almost being swallowed
the word leviathan appears in the tanakh
six times
twice in the book of job twice in palms
and twice in the book of isaiah the
description however isn't always the
same isaiah 27 mentions the torturous
serpent leviathan that resides in the
sea the leviathan is described as a
great fire breathing monster with
impenetrable scales
the book of job perhaps gives us the
most detailed explanation of its
appearance when job begins to question
his place and belief in god
god describes a fire breathing terror
that lurks in the ocean a monster that
embodies chaos an untamed beast that
mankind could never dream to overcome
the only one who can stop this beast is
god himself
so job and anyone else questioning their
place in this hierarchy should
acknowledge they have much more to learn
in mesopotamian and babylonian mythology
we see what are considered some of the
first accounts of the leviathan or
creatures that are very similar
the babylonian creation myth tells of a
primordial goddess of the sea known as
tiamat
who mates with abzu the god of fresh
water
in one variation tirmat is the goddess
of creation and this marriage to absu
slowly begins to create the cosmos as
they have children the second variation
is much closer to the leviathan we saw
in christianity
tiamat is a monster that embodies chaos
and takes the form of a serpent or
dragon
the first generation of deities in this
pantheon are born from tiamet
however their children plan to overthrow
them
abzu is killed when trying to defend his
throne and so tiramat assumes the form
of a wicked monster and seeks vengeance
to aid her she created all of the
monsters in the world
eventually she was slain by the god
marduk who created the heavens and the
earth from her body
the leviathan has taken many different
forms but i guess the more interesting
question here is which creature do you
think inspired its appearance the most
as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
you